on dit de détroit qu'elle a une âme
donnez lui une chance elle vous
surprendra et vous fera vibrer
sa renaissance et miraculeuse son
effervescence contagieuse
[Musique]
un des symboles de cette relance le
tramway qui arpente depuis le printemps
passé la colonne vertébrale de la ville
l'avenue immo droit 1-2 reliant le
district financier des universités
prestigieuses et le complexe sportif de
détroit dont le tout nouvel aréna des
red wings c'est un partenariat public
privé de 140 millions de dollars le kg
hollande comme on l'appelle est le
premier tramway ya des trois ans 60 ans
un projet qui attire des investissements
immobiliers selon l'opérateur du tramway
les terrains et d'édifices blacks ont
été achetés les affiches annonçant de
nouveaux développements se multiplier au
total 7 milliards de dollars ont été
investis ou le seront prochainement dans
des projets immobiliers le long du
trajet de cinq kilomètres allant du
centre ville au nord de détroit
une renaissance incroyable trois ans à
peine après que la ville de détroit est
émergé de la faillite
visite d'un des plus importants
chantiers de transformation en ville la
réfection de la bvk tower construite
dans les années 20
burberry est vacante depuis une décennie
la bvk towers sera transformé en hôtel
et condos d'ici cinq ans des débris
partout via l'imprimante et mannequin de
couture rappelle que le temps s'était
arrêté pendant si longtemps à detroit
depuis deux ans les équipes mené par
john church qui nettoie l'intérieur de
l'édifice
ils n'ont même pas pu commencer les
travaux de réfection il faudra ensuite
réparer les dommages infligés par le roi
les fuites d'eau et les éléments ajoutés
à la longue liste de travaux la
décontamination à l'amiante
c'est le chantier le plus important à
détroit en ce moment et qui dit
restauration easterly aussi réfection de
l'extérieur de l'édifice selon les plans
originaux sort dix prises optiques et
9200 l'ornementation en terre cuite
italienne usé par le temps doit être
remplacé c'est en fabriquant des mollahs
partir des sections les moins abîmée
qu'on parviendra à refaire la façade
pour la renaissance de détroit est
piloté par bedrock une des entreprises
du milliardaire d'angry birds fondateur
de la firme de courtage hypothécaire
quicken loans
il a déjà investi plus de 2 milliards au
centre-ville et 95 édifices ont été
transformées un hôtel de luxe verra
aussi le jour en plein centre ville et
ce qui deviendra le plus haut
gratte-ciel du michigan est en
construction depuis le mois dernier le
site au dessus une tour à bureaux et
résidentiels de cinquante huit étages
non car c'est ce que la relance de
détroit a permis les microsoft et autres
entreprises de haute technologie adopte
la ville de l'automobile qui l'eût cru
détroit fait maintenant compétition à la
silicon valley valérie aido qu'elle a
quitté toronto pour venir participer à
ce projet fou de réanimer une ville
qu'on croyait cliniquement morte elle a
ouvert une boutique de robes de mariée
de luxe ses clientes viennent même de la
californie et valérie rêve maintenant de
faire compétition aux plus grands
couturiers de new york
mais la relance se fait attendre dans
les quartiers résidentiels encore miné
par les maisons abandonnées et la faible
valeur des propriétés
onze mille maisons vacantes ont été
démolies ces dernières années et un
modeste programme de réhabilitation a vu
le jour l'an passé les systèmes
électriques et de chauffage ont été
refaits ainsi que la plomberie en
moyenne 85 mille dollars sont investis
dans chacune des 80 maisons abandonnées
refaite puis revendus ensuite à perte
un autre programme philanthropique
piloté par le milliardaire john gilbert
qui vise à densifier six quartiers
résidentiels et aussi à attirer de
nouveaux résidants ainsi qu'à faire
grimper les valeurs des propriétés
certains cyniques affirme que ce serait
la firme d'hypothèques de dan gilbert
qui en profiteraient par la suite
même s'il reste beaucoup à faire la
renaissance de détroit est bien réelle
une renaissance que salue d'ailleurs le
guide touristique lonely planet qui
place des trois au deuxième rang des
villes du monde à visiter ce thème